[Music]
all right I have a freaking hilarious as
video this is our favorite man Florida
man oh you know like in the headline
Florida man oh okay oh I thought my
James Cage white why that's our favorite
people
very cool Billy sir swag you like banana
I love banana I ate orange for dessert
and prize ladies having strokes let's go
yes some more glasses to Joe as well you
gotta follow um okay all the Asian guy I
ever gonna have a girlfriend
my mommy so sad mommy so disappointing
me yeah I keep thinking is a wife yeah I
keep thinking as an old white guy right
it takes me a lot of process okay Oh
James Cage way
this middle name is sick cage it's very
sick Nicholas Johnny Cage cage
why does cage sound some more combats
dude you never played on Mortal Kombat's
anyway I want to show you guys this
hilarious video and like I said it's a
Florida man ah yes
what's so happier these are my people oh
great what's so happy about it he's
[ __ ] back
it's such a big-ass dude like wait oh
god I'm going into this far god damn it
I need toothpaste
dude that guy's [ __ ] violent I kicked
his own ass he's like next time I come
here I'm not I'm leaving in a [ __ ]
stretcher watch yeah this took place in
Orlando and like you guys saw the
employee the Walmart employee was not
allowing this man to enter the store
because of the fact that you didn't have
a man the other guy approached him he
was like dude you're getting like your
[ __ ] germs everywhere it was like
spitting yeah and the guy was like you
leave me alone which some people looked
at that it was like is he being racist
Oh God course they did Oh God but the
funny thing is people that are the
aggressors for some odd reason they
think that other people are aggressive
like you're violating personal space
right and I love these videos cuz it's
like you can see how delusional people
are cuz they'll go up don't violate
someone's space don't harass them and
they go why are you harassing me it's
like what follow like the lady with the
go back to Mexico in the liquor store
one she can walk
that little girl that a girl [ __ ]
popped her in a face of amazing violated
her space you touched her you [ __ ]
harassed her baby was waiting for her to
touch her and she was like touch my
[ __ ] - [ __ ] touch your Swart walk and
then but in her mind she thought she was
being harassed right it's insane to me
like yeah it's [ __ ] crazy you're
walking towards him but they're sick I
don't get it either people are [ __ ]
insane I also love everyone who thinks
they know the law oh god yeah I know the
law and I go ahead touch me I wish you
would touch me all you gotta do is touch
me I can literally kill you no you can't
record me in public or I didn't give you
permission or else oh like the [ __ ] are
you an actor and you're like you can't
use my like [ __ ] your your it's my right
to not wear a mask it's like did you're
in a private business my god have you
been seeing those videos from that [ __ ]
the white [ __ ] from the townhall me
like the townhall meetings there's
Orange County town hall meeting yeah oh
I am an American like she's just [ __ ]
loud as [ __ ] for some reason people are
insane and they say what their whole
chest ya know and then the other one was
like you are sentencing us to death
because we are breathing in the carbon
carbon what carbon dioxide dioxide I get
a mix up carbon dioxide and so because
of that reason we can't wear math
because we're you're leading us toward
so that's the thing the thing is they're
like the math God they say the math
don't block anything but for some reason
it blocks the air coming out and their
breathing in the carbon dioxide I don't
understand out but and then what about
doctors they weren't all day forever
almost every day but they're fine you
[ __ ] people when they say that they're
an American that it's like they're so
close to coming it's just it's right
there it's so fun to watch yeah the hell
a mask are you man exactly it doesn't
make sense to me because I'm like I
spent eight
hours+ just should be dead by now math
gone when I worked in the hospital for
five years that was bad and even when it
comes down to it even if it doesn't work
it's a matter of respect and caring for
your fellow person you know what I mean
like if it's just respect please
yeah I've been seeing people they have
to post on social media here and there
about like when I'm wearing a mask it's
not because I'm being and considerate
it's like actually the opposite like
people who are wearing masks in public
are actually getting ridiculed by other
people or it's like opposite it depends
on the culture and where you're at right
so when I was at a Walmart by magic
Mountain over there it's very different
and I had I got out of my car at my mask
on and then one of the workers was like
breathe the air it's great it's a great
day what are you doing Joe selection bro
I'm thinking about other people and then
this one this won't fly maybe at the
Walmarts out here right but to malicious
boots or the hole yeah no chance I'm
just like maybe it's an area thing right
of what people believe because also we
don't all think unanimously in America
there's some states that are just
completely like nothing's going on you
guys see that um that viral video on
Facebook planned emic hmm did you see
that okay so my my aunt sent this to me
and it's a really long video and it's
like this documentary about this lady
who worked with the government before
and she pretty much the bottom line here
is that she's saying that coronavirus
was created in a lab by our government
and that they're trying to cause this
whole panic like that conspiracy right
and she said that she worked with dr.
fallacy and vow to you whatever and like
all that stuff and that has like
millions and millions and millions of
views on Facebook and when I cuz it's so
[ __ ] convincing even I was just like
this can't be true like this is too
[ __ ] wild always it the lady that
they imprisoned her because she kind of
knew too much okay that lady so then and
then I was interesting yeah and then I
text
a friend I was just like no way this
this can't be true like if this is true
this makes me feel sick to my stomach
like how can human 'ti be so [ __ ]
evil and then they were like no no you
got to watch the rebuttal to this so
then I watch the this one youtuber
doctor I forgot his name but he broke
down the entire video and like explained
every single point and I was like okay
this is good but a lot of people are
just seeing this Facebook video they
just immediately think this is all a
huge hoax no one's wearing a mat no one
should be wearing a mask they're all
trying to control us somehow and like
this is all for a bigger plan and so
because of that reason a lot of people
are skeptical that's the scary part
about all this I when I message my
different like doctor friends they hold
MDS they have completely opposing
viewpoints so like and they're both
scientists they're both practitioners
and like you would think there's like
some general consensus but they all have
opposing viewpoints so like I'm like
damn this is crazy I still know what
then we can't deny the fact that the
government is taking advantage of this
pandemic it's clearly being done with
the fed being robbed so that's not even
a conspiracy it's an outright heist the
Fed being rough well it's like the 2008
recession right what's what's basically
happening is right in front of our eyes
we see money being printed and
preferential treatments happening to the
people with power right in front of our
eyes the people that are getting all of
the money over yeah the yeah all the
other all the bailouts right
Wall Street boooo right and in small
businesses and individuals are getting
scraps and it's happening but the
average individual just doesn't
understand economics to the point where
they go oh yeah it makes sense this is
this is straight stealing so it's
difficult I think there's a lot of
people that are up against it we call
conspiracy theorists for even saying
that [ __ ] which is wild because they
didn't take the money they did hand it
up to talk to these people it did go to
all these huge businesses it didn't go
to all these other places they do say
that they sent money to small businesses
or small businesses were like we never
got money there are some small
businesses well there's not money
there's independent
economists that calculated each
individual should have got about $20,000
I've been saying you've got about a
thousand two hundred and is that really
enough as a way to help the people
I don't think three months ago [ __ ]
right rent wise no [ __ ] no right and
then they have this trickle-down
economics argument of you give it to the
big businesses they survive which I
agree with some essential businesses but
not banking you know what I mean like
and that's what happened during the 2008
recession get scaled up the car
dealership same [ __ ] yeah in 2008 same
[ __ ] feel like a lot of these people go
to his businesses without their mess
just a start [ __ ] like that lady and I
think she's like in Irvine or something
it's just approval point yeah she
already she's already recording and then
when they ask her to mess [ __ ] I don't
need to worry I have a medical but I
think they just do it just to do it and
post it and they ever say I think
everyone's hungry for a rage right now
so they're looking for any tiny little
ounce of rage where they can like move
like [ __ ] feet out of I just feel
important just really she'll upload and
be like you know they've didn't let me
go into the store today she just feels
important for a day weird as long as
we're watching all this and not and
distracted on this kind of [ __ ] and not
on what we're talking about which is the
fleecing of the American economy you
know it sure feels good doesn't it - I
think watch them silly guy with the mask
good good beat or what I think that's
the issue right is that what humans
value when I say humans the general
public values and what's really
important what we need to fix is always
not important enough for people don't
see how important it is yeah so rage
cycle focuses on the wrong yeah exact
okay that's what it is is because we
have we we have we have the [ __ ] [ __ ]
end of the stick right so we have to
deal with each other being frustrated
broke angry racist wonderful writer of
no health care right so we have all this
anger where we're directing this energy
toward the wrong culprit in my opinion
and we've been locked up and we've been
locked up yeah so I think that a lot of
people are just kind of doing it in
their own way but they're directing
their energy into the wrong places well
because they not too many people really
look at what's really happening globally
and they see what
happening just from their own lens yeah
and they're just like well this has my
attention this is all I know
so focusing on this right now and
there's so many different schools of
thought like there's you know conspiracy
theorists coming out saying that this
was a manufactured pandemic there's you
know people that are like no this is
real and kovat is dangerous and you got
to be careful or whatever so it's like
how do you get a whole nation to go
under one fire on one thing and agree
it's super difficult oh they love that
everyone so divided like [ __ ] less
power right if you already have [ __ ]
mountains of money you're sitting a lot
of cash and then all these commercial
businesses are [ __ ] all these
mom-and-pop shops are especially super
[ __ ] you come in you should a pop all
those commercial real estate you get to
consolidate your power the rich get
richer that's happening everywhere by
the way and also two million people
we're tracking right now - too many
people losing their mortgages this year
that's worse than 2008 we're talking
about year-over-year two million people
a year
that's worse than it was in 2008 so it's
not people are here whining about my
rights wearing a mask it's as sad as it
ever was
saying that ever was and nobody [ __ ]
cares about you until the election
doesn't matter right it's all about vote
for my side vote for my side I'm gonna
run on these issues and then do nothing
that's what they do every [ __ ] time I
guess they might like overtime like
where do you see this country heading
then some people are taking [ __ ]
civil wars a place has been for 30 years
everyone talking about the same issues
but no progress right now you had the
Democrats in power they had a
supermajority
they had Obama they had the House and
Senate they didn't get one vote from a
Republican for Obamacare and it was
written by the [ __ ] insurance
industry so the idea that there is a
group in there fighting for you and they
want to give you health care all this
[ __ ] no one's fighting for the interest
of the public it's all corporate yeah we
have a corporate oligarchy both parties
working together and when government do
this though like I mean I'm not a
history buff at all but from what I
understand with other countries when
this has happened in their governments
that's when like like who's come out
solution exactly good now when people
are pushed without basic survival needs
it's happening and people feel helpless
so I think you're starting to see a
little bit of it and it's it's really
not a [ __ ] wonder
really it really shouldn't blow too many
people's minds either yeah but let's all
get mad about whatever the news let's
get mad about people not wearing masks
or for people or people vandalizing
statues that's what's really scary right
now there's also there's also that one
aircraft carrier that had a culvert case
so that the park it when we talked about
like picking that one captain that he
had a leaked email yeah in the Pacific
okay but here so he he sent it email
like it got leaked and then so I guess
the people were like oh yeah it's good
he's letting people know that we have
Cove it but then the people up top were
like no we're supposed to keep that
secret and then so he I think he
resigned the problem with that is the
aircraft carrier finally docked and
immediately China took that position in
the ocean so it's like a huge global
thing but no one is taking a global
perspective on who is manipulating and
taking advantage of the whole pandemic
[Music]